welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today on the show I have chervin Jeff
fadier he has a podcast called wake the
fake up he's been studying and diving
into sort of the occult nature of things
and esoteric thoughts since he was like
10. we are in a point in time in this on
this planet where we have to wake up and
in the episode you'll hear there's a
timeline for this the conversation had a
lot to do with sovereignty and you know
our children and schools and disease and
viruses and the food and our soil and
just how do we get to a place where we
know who we are and we are sovereign and
that we are going to have a future on
this planet for for a long time to come
in a really positive way instead of this
destructive manner that really hasn't
been going on that long but if we don't
course correct big things are gonna go
the wrong way and so chervin is just a
really wonderful man that is helping to
inspire people and I hope that you're
inspired by this episode so thanks for
stopping by please hit the Subscribe
button and the bell for notifications
and let me know in the comments what
you're doing to be more Sovereign and to
know who you are and to improve your
life
um I'm very curious and I think
everybody else would be too
today's pretty intense partner is
athletic greens I take ag1 by athletic
greens literally every day I gave ag1 a
try because I wanted to nourish my gut
health I wanted to have more energy I
wanted to add more micronutrients to my
body I take it first thing in the
morning before I have coffee and then
before I go work out it makes me feel so
good I'm giving my body the nutrition it
craves if a comprehensive solution is
what you need from your supplement
routine then try ag1 and get a free
one-year supply of vitamin D and get
five free ag1 travel packs with your
first purchase go to drink ag1.com
pretty intense that's
drinkag1.com pretty intense check it out
how was your world these days
still good actually I've been in a a
really nice run over the last 30 days
deep diving and going back to a lot of
my my rituals a lot of my old practices
and it's really calming the craziness
that's all around me and everything
that's going on with my company and
it's been great I mean I didn't know
that
you know vitamin D was a hormone until I
started doing all this health stuff yep
so hormones yeah it's the it's the
body's reaction to
any light source for the most part
mainly infrared and UVA and UVB light
it's like it's part of a signal pathway
that's how it just shows you how insane
light is what light actually means in
this world well it's everything it's
everything I mean it's like without
light everything dies I would think
including us
yeah well nothing would be able to
receive information without light
is actually it's it's a message
and it's transcribing so much
information right when you see it as
like something that illuminates
something so our photoreceptors in our
eyes can receive information process it
and then create an image in the part of
our brain like you see my face I'm
seeing your face that's because we're
you know basically circulating within
each other
um but it's so much more because we of
course are going to get all into the
edges of what's really going on I
totally have been thinking I don't know
if you have thought this at all but
there's so much blockage of the sun
these days it feels like and like
finally people are looking up and being
like oh why is this guy look like a grid
and you know it is completely confirmed
through news and the government that
they do spray chemicals in the air and
that Chemtrails are a real thing
obviously the last few years have been
nuts and there's been so many things to
put us into a fierce State and put us
keep us indoors
avoiding the light actually my friend
just sent me a Instagram video that
showed someone walking on the streets
and somewhere in LA and there's an
advertisement for a building to live in
that's a that's an underground building
like oh yeah
I mean like to you don't need to go
outside again and I just feel like they
are trying to now depress us and drive
us crazy without by blocking sunlight
and and sure enough it usually seems
like whenever those Chemtrails are up
there the next day is cloudy absolutely
research tell us yeah you know I mean
I've been talking about this for 15
years you know I've to the point where
it's like it was it was falling on deaf
ears for so long and the whole thing
where no those are contrails when
contrails lost maximum seven seconds in
the atmosphere and you can actually see
that you know they turn on and turn off
and turn on and turn off which ends that
debate right there this has been going
on since the 40s you know it's been you
know weather modification
um you know weaponizing weather and
really understanding that this is this
is a serious problem which is basically
evolved into this concept where we're
not observing the Earth because that's
really how they're rolling it out is
that they're blocking UVA and UVB rays
because of global warming that's the
whole story now and that's the
geoengineering story is that what an
awesome way of keeping the core of the
earth cool and keeping the surface of
the Earth cool by spraying metallic
atmospheric particulates strontium
barium aluminum into the into the into
the Sky cover and have it reflect the
sun back out into space that's the story
it's such an Abomination it's so gnarly
this is an existential threat in my
opinion
um this is something that you just you
can't walk away from because this stuff
is making its way everywhere it's
getting it's microns size so it's
getting into people's lungs it's getting
into the soil and like you said father
son I mean that is that's our core
energy source of every biochemical in
nature and in our body and it's part of
the production of the life cycle that's
we're dealing with some strange stuff
and the whole thing did you see my post
yesterday I was talking about you know
this we we need the life force of the
Sun but we also have to understand the
Sun so it's not like you can't just be
someone who wears sunblock for 20 years
and then take a trip to Costa Rica and
think that you can just go stand in
front of the Sun for 12 hours right it
there's a common sense approach and this
whole beauty industry about the sunlight
is you know damaging you and dangerous
to you again Common Sense approach
sunlight gives you life sunlight
activates 3000 genes associated with
longevity that we know of wow it's it's
you know it's the Core Essence of our
circadian rhythm so without sunlight On
The Rise if you're not getting it into
your eyes and getting it onto your body
your body's immune system is not turning
on your clock isn't turning on I can go
on and on melatonin is produced from
sunlight and melatonin we know is not
just the sleep you know hormone it's
actually one of the strongest
antioxidants in our system even more
than glutathism why when the Sun goes
down does it serve does it have a why is
there a melatonin surge right because
it's when the Sun goes down that the
surge of melatonin comes that's correct
yeah so it's building that reservoir on
the rise so the the Rising Sun builds
the reservoir of melatonin and then and
then the body responds by releasing that
melatonin throughout the brain and body
and intracellularly as the sun makes its
declination to the Easter to the east so
as the sun moves away from us and as
long as we're not you know shrouded in
you know I would say pollutionary light
blue light spectrums like that melatonin
expands and releases throughout the body
and serves as a major antioxidant and
it's it's actually creating redox in the
body where it's lending electrons to
free radicals throughout the body from
brain to toe very interesting and that's
why you know I'm sure you've been in a
campfire or you know fires everything
right so fire is very similar with the
sun's Rays to a certain extent it's
offering certain nanometers of light
waves and infrared
which is leading to the system and it's
actually releasing stress and cortisol
throughout the body that's why you sit
in front of a fire for an hour in a camp
you're ready to go to sleep usually you
have the best sleep ever yeah or if you
have the ability to get a red light they
recommend doing red light sunrise sunset
to mimic because really red light is
just pulling a certain a little narrow
spectrum of what the sun offers
um right to help with the Circadian
rhythm and help with sort of waking up
and going to sleep and keeping because
it's about the Rhythm right that's right
yep and I do red light every other day
on the rise and almost every evening
um you know around 7 30 8 o'clock yeah
and uh it's part of the ritual and it's
so many benefits on just everything I
mean it's all common sense with your
health you know it's not like we can
isolate or looking at it allopathically
you know it's like red light raises ATP
or red light lowers cytochrome b or
whatever it is we get sometimes so
allopathic that we don't realize that by
it doing one thing means it's doing so
many other things and it's got an
evolutionary aspect to it that's part of
our entire Doctrine and our physiology
of Being Human and that's where the
spirit comes into play so we get out of
the left brain analytical biohacking
energy and we start looking at these
things as evolutionary and understanding
that the human body was designed with a
set of instructions you know we're Earth
made you know you and you and I are
filled with minerals of the earth like
how trippy is that body is actually made
of what we walk on right and we don't
even know we don't even know what's
under us
such a trip that's why we have to ground
to the Earth that's why we drink spring
water that's why we mineralize our body
oh I think I saw you say something
something about being careful how much
of that you put in your water for
hydration is that true how much of what
specifically minerals and salt or you
know sodium potassium chlorine the all
the different minerals and whatnot is
that dangerous or is it good to put it
in your water all the time I think it
depends like you know some person's
medicines another person's poison we
have to really approach things
practically with who we are where we are
why we are how we live our lives things
of that nature you know and so
mineralization is foundation to health
getting electrolytes getting sea salt in
your body especially on the rise
especially around your vigorous workouts
it's critical but you can overdo it of
course and then there's wrong form
minerals things that are made you know
industrial you know byproduct products
that have no no basis of being in our
body and actually create damage and
hardening of the body that's when you
get fibrotic tissue and over
calcification of the body and things of
that nature and so our body again I came
with a set of instruction we have we
have Cycles in our life you know my
body's different than when I was 14
right and so it's it requires different
things at different stages there's a
24-hour cycle there's a seven day cycle
and there's a 28-day cycle and a seven
year cycle in the way that we need to
approach our health and this is
additional Chinese herbal medicine this
is an ayurvedic approach but they all
correlate with new formed understanding
of how our immune system works how stem
cells work in the body all these
different things
um all kind of you know meet together at
some at some Summit it's a lot of cool
stuff here this is this is what I love
to this is what I love to do you know
I'm glad you mentioned stem cells that I
was curious I wasn't sure we'd get to it
or not but um so you're talking about
these Cycles is there something
appropriate for each cycle like the one
day the one week the 28 days and the
seven years as their use in those Cycles
is it like hey every day you should be
doing this and every week you should
make sure you include this or is it more
of a Cascade that when you do each day
right it leads into the next seven years
you'll be a different body because every
seven years we have a whole new body is
that correct that's right and we go
through it we go through a shift every
seven years in the in the multiple
complex systems in the body whether it's
our you know you know our neuro system
our cardio system our digestive system
all of those things they shift a little
bit things change hormones change
thyroid changes
um the way that we receive information
changes our oral health changes all
those things start to make a different
shift and so you're right how you do
anything is how you do everything so
every day you know you're creating an
opportunity to not only you know get
feel healthy but to thrive and to get
better and better I do think that there
are systems
um depending on people's Constitution
um that would you know lead us into
stronger health and lead us into more of
a resilient Health uh you hear a lot of
the geneticists today talking about how
we have a health span and we have a
disease span and once you leave the
health span you enter the disease span
and getting back to the health span once
you're in the disease state is a lot
more difficult than keeping a life
filled in that state and we're in
interesting times you know it is what
what's happened over the last hundred
years to our atmosphere like we just
talked about to our water to our soil to
our food to our education to the fear to
the scarcity all of these things are
destructionary forces that are the
opposite of centropy which is a place of
symbiotic Evolution where everything is
coming together to create a utopic
paradise and we're in such fight flight
rage High to energy with scarcity then
you have all the physiological aspects
that are falling apart we're not getting
sunlight we're living in in industrial
warehouses you know we're living in
artificial boxes we're controlling the
temperature and the lighting not pulled
away from nature that right there in
itself doesn't allow us to pull on to to
our hormetic codes and what do I mean by
that hormesis that which does not kill
you makes you stronger and so we're no
longer hunting for our spring water and
you know growing our own food and
putting in all this effort for the
sustainable things that we need to
survive and so that's not activating
well they call it now sirtuin Pathways
longevity Pathways so we're just you
know we're sedentary more than ever you
know we're we're sitting on the couch
we're laying in our bed we're sitting in
a car we're doing all these things these
things are keeping us from pulling on
the strings of being active and pulling
on the strings of surviving like where's
what is our trajectory with that kind of
accumulation of of issues and of you
know reduction of humanism almost
yeah well you're seeing it right now
unfold all around us I mean we're at
we're at crisis level with
cardiovascular diseases and
cardiovascular events which is a
byproduct of metabolic diseases for the
most part and inflammatory diseases I'm
not even talking about cancers and
lymphomas and all those things you know
we've never been at this level of
obesity and
um that right there skyrocks skyrockets
into
um you know being overridden by
pathogens and toxins and parasites and
infections and Lyme where otherwise our
immune system is able to handle all of
these and then you have the sexually
transmitted diseases that are running
haywire and then now we have
neurodegenerative diseases that are I'm
watching these stats stats and I'm like
I've never seen this level of dementia
and Parkinson's and these are just names
that someone gave them what are we
talking about right now we're talking
about the effect of the Neurology of the
brain is not wiring correctly and it's
hardening and it's filled with toxins
and it can't release itself through its
lymphatic system which is the lymph node
of the brain you throw that in and now
we're not sleeping properly it's it's
Haywire now I don't want this to be Doom
and Gloom like our atmosphere
but uh I I think by by understanding
what's going on and not putting your
head in the stand and saying Namaste we
have we we it gives us the opportunity
to look at ourselves
and figuring out hey am I do I want to
keep playing this game or is my karma
going to change based on something that
I'm doing with my Free Will and that's
really what that's all I talk about I
mean if you listen to any of my content
everything I'm doing out there I'm not
trying to catch the the viral wave of
social media or get involved in all that
escapism I'm not playing into
that part and I and the same thing I've
noticed with you is that you're you're
standing in your truth and you're
talking about things that matter and
you're not just trying to like catch on
the next Trend I
um I I'm so against the I almost think
it's more destructive to be talking
about regurgitated drivel to get more
people that just want to escape to your
content right versus talking about
things that matter and these those
things feel reactive where when you're
in your truth and you're following sort
of uh intuition and Curiosities
then it feels like you're more on the
Leading Edge as opposed to just kind of
following the masses and what is
clickbaity and what is
um what is a Hot Topic it's like
you know some that will never evolve
because it's reactionary so for me I I
this podcast is totally my Curiosities
it is like my guilty pleasure and I and
I also love meeting people and just my
network has become so wide and
interesting and
um so yeah I think I think you're right
and I I give you props for you know
being able to stay in that state in that
truth I mean symbiotica how long has
symbiotica been around and was there
something before symbiotica because I
knew I mean I've been taking your
products for a long time
um but was there something before that
I before I answer that I just wanted to
say I receive all that with such Clarity
and and that resonates so much that the
purpose behind this is the Curiosity
it's the investigator and that's part of
my human design that's in my Jean Keys
I've had that since day one being born
into this body in this realm whatever
this is It's curiosity and wanting to
know more
and so I appreciate you saying that yeah
I have a curious question
um
do you find that when you are in that
space which you are obviously most of
the time
um do you find that you actually
end up asking all the right questions
that are extremely pertinent or like
that end up like weaving into this whole
like wow I can't believe I asked about
that and then you were wearing that and
then you told me the story about that
and then all of a sudden and it feels
almost like your information is far more
Divine and higher self than it is
actually intellectualized it's actually
channeled in a way do you do you define
that 100 we've gotten too far off into
the intellectualism which is because
which has created too much of a heady
space where free thought and divine
connection and you know all the things
that are buried within our DNA is not
able to surface because of that left
brain analytical lockdown and that's
part of the Matrix that we're in right
now that's part of the you know the
school systems that we're in we're bred
to be indoctrinated with information for
recall as opposed to activation
philosophy and I think there's a place
for both meeting together in an
intersection I I think you can't have
one without the other and that's part of
my pedigree as an anthroposophist and
growing up with Rudolph Steiner
teachings and part of my entire makeup
in my embodiment is finding that balance
between
knowledge-based information and also the
ability to access higher attainment from
your soul I mean if you think about it
you are the cosmic goo of all your
ancestors you know and everyone's always
talking about past lives and all these
different things
um and there isn't specific ways of
legitimizing it it's an overall network
of understanding that we are we come
from a source and we are carrying on so
much genetic information that we can't
even comprehend and if that's the case
if each part of those genes are carrying
that kind of information it's no wonder
why we're feeling such a connection to
our ancestors there's so much
information out there that's coming to
us so I agree with you and I and I do
feel that there are moments where it's
time to get analytical and it's time to
look at the data and it's time to be an
intellectual but then there's times to
remove all that information and to go
into a complete open wide open Channel
and and open up the heart and open up
the connection to to source and usually
I do that with all the other things off
and all and going into that quiet space
and that's why we do vipassanas that's
why we spend you know two three months
in the jungles with shamans that's why
we go through these initiations it's
been a wild life you know where I've
come from and what I've gone through to
get here you know I didn't just wake up
one day and all of a sudden you know
these things were happening around me
this was a this was a life that
the opportunity communities came to me
and I accepted them and
back to your question about subnautica
um you know I was I'm the firstborn son
of a pretty cool Persian family uh that
goes back five six thousand years and I
was the first born son out of that
entire lineage that was born here in
North America my my dad immigrated from
Iran
and that's kind of a trip when I I
realized that at age like five or six
you know growing up in La Jolla
California I was like wait a second
I I'm not from here my all my grandpas
the last five six thousand years maybe
longer
grew up in one area of Northern Iran
and I'm the first born son out of that
entire lineage if you look at an entire
chart that's crazy it's crazy and I and
I and I I remember feeling into that at
such an early age like what the hell I'm
speaking English
weren't you what's your family also
zoroastrian in real in religion or
spiritual practices which is I believe
to be the oldest religion
that we know of correct that's correct
yeah you know that yeah that's right and
that's the Ancient Ancient you know
faith-based system was the first Christ
system where you had a Christ a Huda
Mazda and then you had the Antichrist
which was the devil and it's it's
interesting that that was you know five
thousand years before Christ 4 500 years
before Christ and that was the
um you know that was the I would say the
impetus to to want to reach more into my
background and understand my culture and
I I felt at an early age that that this
life mattered you know I was old soul
seven and then because of that I don't
know it just called in all these mentors
and at age nine you know David wolf my
cousin who was creating the raw food
movement at that time I was I was
literally a child while this guy was
becoming the most famous raw foodist in
the world and this is my mom's sister
son and he's half Persian and what were
the chances that I was involved in that
entire journey and he introduced me to
David Ike when I was 10. no way I read
the truth shall set you free and then
Children of The Matrix at 10. you know I
was like God like how did you even could
you really comprehend because I also
believe that it's you know I try and I
try and talk to people and watch things
and read things that are Beyond me
because I know it'll help me learn but I
mean at 10 you don't even have the
ability to have that kind of discernment
with the information you're taking in so
to be reading and taking in that
information at 10 there you had to have
been like not an old soul an ancient
Soul
I've Danica I felt that I felt
I really felt there was a purpose in my
life at such an early age and that there
was something so Divine going on and I
also I was also angry too there was a
level of anger at that age because I was
learning about you know the U.S foreign
policy and what happened with Iran and
how the implosions of wars happened and
I was learning about all these different
things you know about you know a lot of
the agencies that were involved and so
my mind was in that level it's like
conspiracy theory today's but these are
things I was learning at age 10 and 11
in 1993 and then
um and then when you start piecing
together all the medical system and so
Health was a big part of my uh my
upbringing is that nutrition standard
American diet what they were feeding
kids was so insane and think about it
was just an awareness of that it wasn't
like there was someone sick or because a
lot of times when someone one has such a
passion and then a knowledge about
something it's because it's necessary
and usually we we need it for something
um so it was purely just part of the
puzzle for you is to to this is
something that isn't right and you need
to understand it at first it was before
even someone got sick my mom actually
was diagnosed with breast cancer
I was 14 and I was already you know head
deep in all this stuff
and we're able to get that through that
fairly quickly
um through fasting and raw foods and
enzymes and nutrition and uh
no chemo no chemo no chemo minor surgery
and
um was able to get through that very
quickly but I we were just on the heels
of the 80s which was complete treachery
in the in this world I mean that was if
most people don't know I mean I was a
kid for that I don't really remember
much in terms of what was happening
around me at that time I was just six
seven years old but the 80s was like the
time where you know you had the material
woman you know and what I mean by that
is it was all hyper materialism you know
you had the Woodstock era you had the
LSD psilocybin psychedelic realm
um hippie Revolution the Consciousness
explosion and then the government's like
nope whoa that's too cool for school we
gotta get you a little Dumber well we
got to shut down all of your frequencies
we can't have people dissolving Egos and
loving each other and coming together in
harmony we need to complete complete our
imperialism we had all our Wars I mean
Vietnam was going on but there was cold
Wars everywhere and all this stuff
happening so they immediately turned all
those psychedelics into schedule one
drugs and then open up the floodgates of
alcohol and then ultimately open up the
floodgates of cocaine and so all that
happened in the mid 70s late 70s and
then you had this complete Revolution or
de-evolution of the vine and in the 80s
it was Wall Street
materialism corporate radical
corporations like a chicken with their
heads cut off destroying everything in
sight and nature no oversight whatsoever
and monopolies monopolies and Corruption
and all this stuff the 80s was a
disaster to our mother earth it was a
disaster to our our gnosis and our
psychology and it's also why
after the 80s the the way that it just
led into more craziness with our medical
system and the way that we were birthing
children and the immunization calendars
I mean it was Insanity I think God's
flooding then thank God I missed all
that and did it have a you know it
wasn't you know I wasn't part of all
that but it's devastating so I'm just
making a point on how these things have
been phasing because it's important to
know our history it's important to know
our empirical history you know we we're
so in denial and we're so out of our own
conscious body today because it wasn't
that long ago it wasn't that long ago
the other day and and that's what where
what's going to happen in the next 15 20
years and just think about it and it led
it led towards such craziness and I mean
it makes it makes it makes it seem
likely then that the the the powers that
really are in control would be promoting
non-humanism
because it's a lot easier to not be
human when all this shit's going on
exactly that's exactly right Danica I
hit it right on the nail and that's
interesting because
um Rudolph Steiner is one of my guiding
lights and he's like a father to me in
so many ways what did he what was his um
I've heard him before I I also follow
the work of a guy named Robert Gilbert
and I feel like Robert Gilbert have you
ever heard of him no he does like bio
like a lot of different things when it
comes to frequency a lot when it
frequency and energy and he sort of like
has some sort of ancient Egyptian
teaching teachings that he was able to
bring over here and um uh biogeometry
and all kinds of different things so
anyway he talks about Rudolph Steiner as
well so I'm curious what um what is it
what it what is he all about what did he
do he did a lot and I'm a big fan of
biogeometry yeah higher geometry
throughout my home and all that I feel
like I need to renovate an entire like I
need to start a house from scratch with
like appropriate Ley lines like Crystal
grids like the house being the right
shape and design and orientation
um our living environment our living
environment is real that's a part of
being human and you know we're not
supposed to have you know 90 degree
walls and and all these things it just
energetically cuts us off but not to go
off into that tangent yeah that's a fun
one that's a different one we can we can
definitely create an own podcast around
that I I spent a lot of time in that
conversation and I love architecture and
that's a whole thing
um yeah Rudolph Steiner is a is a sage
he's a he is a Guiding Light to our
world it's a clairvoyant scientist a
cultist Master genius and just gave his
entire life to the world and
investigated everything out there for
you know that you can imagine from
Aristotle and Plato to the ancient to
the ancient vedics to the Persian Empire
to all of that wow and
um he was an austrian-born wizard with
that kind of Clairvoyance he created
biodynamic farming and Waldorf education
and you're familiar with Waldorf yeah
yeah it's all through the government
Steiner's work and
um more most importantly to me is he
built or he channeled a cosmology of
where we are today in this realm and
that cosmology is our connection to
um you know our sky clock our connection
to the Earth and our Consciousness with
it and his whole thing is that we live
in a trinity it's non-dualistic and what
he meant by that what yeah so it's a
non-duality it's not good versibo it's
it's not even looking at things with
that kind of lens as soon as we start
looking at that lens we lose sight of
our Guiding Light and who we are and
where we are and so he coined it very
interesting this is very powerful
he he he channeled that there is a
luciferic energy in this world and
Lucifer is the bearer of light most
people who hear of Lucifer they think of
a slithering demon coming to get you
from underground and pull you into hell
that's not what Lucifer Lucifer is the
bearer of light it's the Temptation it's
the ego it's correlated with our blood
in the body it's the fire it's the
hyper-spiritual it's the Super Hyper
religious it's being completely
disconnected from your Earth body and
connected to the fundamentals of what of
what Earth is how to get so Twisted
because we have to have something to
hate divide and conquer
possibly it's it's it's being so outside
of your body and your thought that it's
becoming irrational
it's it's it's too spiritual to
comprehend that's the and and you are
the Savior mentality you've seen it with
a lot of stories of people saying I'm
the Divine you know messenger you know I
I am this I am that and creating
followers and wanting to be revered as
The Guiding Light that's a luciferic
tendency and that's a Lucifer compulsion
oh wow and then on the polar opposite is
the aramonic energy which comes from
ahraman which is the deity from
Zoroastrianism that Steiner Steiner
brought in that for his cosmology which
is the the deity of materialism that you
are only flesh and bone that there's no
such thing as soul in your body that you
are Earthbound and aramon expresses
itself through government science
materialism
all the things that are shrouded in
artificial intelligence computers
statistics all the things that we are
today and so today is the age of
Ultraman you know the last 2000 years
2500 years was a very luciferic realm
you can see it in all the stories you
could see it in the way that the
scriptures work and all these things
it's hyper spirituality over the last
four or five hundred years the aramonic
energy has made its way into our Earth
plane and Steiner 100 years ago said a
hundred years from now we are going to
be in the core impulse of ahraman and
we'll have 20 years to snap out of it if
we don't snap out of it in the next 20
years that's from 2020 to 2040 we're
going to enter something called the
eight sphere and the eight sphere is
something like the movie Wall-E or it's
a dystopic world where we've completely
forgotten what we've forgotten we have
no more connection to our soul we have
no more connections ancestors we've
become completely though because right
now we're like and we're like man why
are we why are we uh as Graham Hancock
would say why are we uh why are we a
race of Amnesia that's right the fact
that we have awareness that we have
amnesia means there's still something
there but you're saying that if we don't
make this transition by 2040 that we
won't even know that there was a past we
won't even have we won't be aware of
Amnesia that's absolutely correct we're
forgetting it through generations and
we're at generation lost right now and
it's getting worse and the Advent of
artificial intelligence technology data
capture which is pulling the child out
of the present and is not allowing the
child to develop internal faculties of
being in nature being connected to
Spirit which again goes back to
biodynamic farming and Waldorf education
and all these principles of developing
internal faculties based on the true
life as opposed to this fake radiation
controlled device
and this is the system we're we're in
we're in desperate times and it's
getting dangerous and the Christ impulse
the Christ conscious is the balance
between materialism and this so that's
the third the Christ Consciousness is
the third it's right in the middle
it's the middle way and Christ is
embodying that we are Earth bodies that
we have these flesh suits but also
knowing that there's a deep spiritual
yeah embodiment and we have to
understand these Tendencies we've got to
understand araman we got to understand
Lucifer and not look at them as demons
or being scared of them or anything we
have to we have to study them it's the
it's the lack of looking at it and
understanding it that creates the
problem and that's what these two
entities want they want you to not know
what that they are there
yeah I mean I I let's like get into
something tangible how do you with that
awareness of this sort of Trinity of
dynamic which trinities are something
that you hear about over and over and
over again and as we're talking about
zoroastrian and that certain prophecy
certain things were the there was a
religion and Christ like Consciousness
um practice thousands of years before
Christ I mean it makes me think of the
movie Zeitgeist and how you know that
for the first time that was where I saw
it where I was like oh wow this is a
pattern that has reoccurred over and
over and over again in history with uh
you know with a Christ like figure
certain names dates all the things line
up in a in a cyclical sort of fashion so
what do we do with this awareness of
this Trinity what is how does this
actually help our life yeah so the
Zeitgeist you know they show you the
Egyptian perspective you know of Toth
and show you that that's very similar
with the Christ story and then you look
at the bastrianism it's exactly
identical with the Christ story with the
both people and the disciples all the
numbers are matching up and so for me
you know it's all coding there's some
kind of coding going on and we're this
is why you love Robert Edward Grant
isn't it yeah yeah this is why me and
him could talk for for days straight
totally and um and so we have to we have
to take heed to this and if this is
something that interests you
then you go deeper and you start looking
at your life well I highly advise
everyone to to understand this Trinity
but also look at yourself look at your
life you know do a forensic audit on
your experience every day and so Rudolph
Steiner was a Rosa crucian
so I practice Rose secretionism
practicing it for 15 years oh cool
there's another Robert Gilbert thing he
began okay now I know who Robert Gilbert
is yeah right strong clear character I
like him I like him a lot
um I I think he's done videos on
Rosicrucianism right okay correct and so
he he along with others and myself you
do an audit on your reality that's how
you that's a spiritual science why why
are we not investigating ourselves and
our Consciousness and our behavioral
patterns you ask anyone that wants to
upgrade their life whether it's a life
coach or whatever it is is you have to
investigate your patterns you have to
investigate your day and it starts by
investigating your day and so before I
go to bed I do an audit on my day I
replay
all my interactions to the best of my
ability and once you get started doing
this after a week two weeks three weeks
you get better and you're actually
creating neuroplasticity you know
because you're not just like letting
things go and this isn't something where
you sit there and you're dwelling on
your day or you're dwelling on your life
in fact it's the opposite because how
are you supposed to grow and get better
if you're not analyzing your reactions
to things and what caused you to escape
and what caused you to tense up and what
things drawn you drew you in what things
Drew you out these are all things that
are pattern interruptions in our daily
lives that if we're not cognizant of
them we're doing the same thing over and
over and over and we're not getting
anywhere and so a deep initiate or a
Rosicrucianism or an anthropocyphus or a
theosophist whatever you want to call it
does these evaluations and usually they
do them before but before bed and
there's a whole cycle to that and I I
always tell people look at your life and
look at your life through the lens of
the Trinity where are you getting too
caught up in the head where are you
caught up in your materialism where are
you identifying yourself with your
materialism and when I say materialism I
don't just mean your fancy homes and
cars and money and all that stuff I'm
talking about deeper where do you where
do you identify with yourself as your
name as your body
right and if you could start getting out
of this thing that your this body that's
that's part of my meditation I go I'm
just this isn't me my name is chervin
that but I'm just I'm just inhabiting
this body
this is a rental
and we can start getting into that level
of samadhi it's almost like yeah
practice of dying before dying it
unlocks things in you of Freedom you
can't even comprehend and this is a core
practice of the philosophy of freedom is
being able to open up the the clutches
of the materialism that this is who you
are your name your body you know all of
these things and
um it creates a lot of freedom and then
on the other side of it is where are you
running away from your body
where are you neglecting your body
how are you not taking care of your body
are you too caught up in fantasy are you
daydreaming too much are you too much in
a victim role do you feel like you're
drifting in a poverty conscious too much
those are all those are all like
luciferic by Nature because they're
taking you out of your identification
and when you can merge those worlds and
get into a state where you're finding
balance between them that's really when
you're you're activating that Christ
within you and what Christ represents
and that is that is a that's a beautiful
sequence to to have all of this feels
like it's leading towards sovereignty
which they know something that you were
curious about talking about and I was
like yes I mean I have a good girlfriend
who her whole spiritual teaching is
based on sovereignty and and I and I
totally believe that we're being called
inward because everything's been so out
and that we don't have any idea what to
even trust anymore so we're the the only
real system that is actually an
incredible lie detector system is us
and so how do we develop more
sovereignty how do we even get to know
ourselves in the landscape of the way
everything looks these days is this like
start the commune start over or how do
we get to that place where we really
know ourself and can become sovereign
that's the greatest question on Earth
today and probably the most important
and critical for our time because
how many people on this Earth today
are living in their Soul's purpose what
they've incarnated here to do and when
you look at that it's like
you know a decimal probably and so if
you have a whole he said Rudolph Steiner
was saying that only a third would be
right like a third I think I heard
something where he's like a third will
be confused a third will be
um you know bringing a third will be in
their Dharma and another third will be
soulless that's right and we can see
that today and even the people that are
going to be in their Dharma they're
still going to be caught up in the hyper
materialism of this world and the you
know the debt slave society and all the
stuff that's happening
um that's so intrusive on our Soul's
journey and taking us out of our element
and so obviously there needs to be some
kind of you know dismantling of the
systems you know this is it's not a
it can't shift anymore it's it has it's
like a revolution has to start over
don't fix what's broken just start over
start over that's gonna have to happen
in order for that to happen though we
need people stepping into their
sovereignty and their freedom and saying
enough stuff I think we see it over the
last three four years especially with
the you know the Abomination we just
went over went through that I I rarely
talk about publicly
um and it's it's waking a lot of people
up you push people too far it gets to
the point where you know you've almost
over indexed what you were trying to
push people to do and now you're you're
seeing people snapping out of their
waking up and mothers are
waking up too which is the most you know
that that right there is the most of
their children or their children you
can't you saw that with the vaccine you
really did you saw that with the vaccine
you're like okay well you know you got
to make me do it but whoa whoa whoa wait
now you're making my kids do it and
that's when you really because they push
too far
you can't push a mother and that was a
fatal mistake and that was I think that
was the
I think that was the Turning of the tide
and I'm and I'm feeling into that
because so many mothers are contacting
me on a daily basis for years and it's
just really beautiful to see people
stepping into their power and really
caring about what is happening around
them and how their kids are being taught
at school and starting home systems and
Waldorf education I I've actually been
asked to create a whole new Waldorf
Paradigm in the Middle East I'm really
excited about being part of that Journey
yeah really really powerful stuff that's
happening and I'm just really you know
does Waldorf exist in the Middle East or
is there nothing like it there's really
nothing like it there's bits and pieces
here and there but it's it's something
that now there's a Renaissance happening
in the Middle East right and you know
people are snapping out of the illusion
and you know America is just kind of
falling apart in so many ways I hate to
say it you know I'm American I love my
country I'm I'm from California and it's
just what what's happened and what's
happening right now is so insane the
cancer culture is so insane and again
these are things that I have to be
careful about what I say just because
the symbiotica
um but most people know where I stand
and I stand in sovereignty so back to
your question how do we become smart
well the body has to be Sovereign first
and foremost yeah that seems so
impossible right now
well we got to get back to the
fundamentals and okay I'm all about
exotic Health Plans detoxification the
best nutrition on Earth the best
supplements on Earth all of these things
those are all fantastic and necessary
but you can't go into those things if
the fundamentals aren't in place and so
if people aren't moving their body
if people aren't you know connected to
the sun if people aren't earthing their
body onto the Earth if people aren't
hydrated properly you know if people
aren't working on their breath getting
oxygen in their body forget about it
don't even think about becoming
Sovereign because your body is not even
a position wow
and these things are crippling our
entire known realm and and it's not a
fad to be in your Earth body connected
to your spirit connected to Nature
that's just where we belonged we got to
get out of these metropolitan cities you
know if you're living on the 40th floor
getting 20 minutes of sunlight every day
drinking your pate and eating until 10
pm at night every night and you know
washing it down with TV and news and all
that stuff alcohol right yeah you're
just that I mean that's a whole nother
level that you're just heading into
you're heading towards a cliff with no
breaks and it's it's tough to see that
but that's also I've also
set back and said this is just part of
the unfolding you know we can't convince
anyone we all just have to embody and so
your daily practices and how you doing
things how you do everything and so
being conscious with your decision
making and and really making the choices
that are going to put you in a position
to thrive this survival energy is not
getting us anywhere everybody's body has
the ability to heal everybody's bodies
has the ability to expand and we all
have the potential to hit Peak Peak
genius it's there but but it's the
system and the decision making is
basically I think creates such a frail
environment from within
um it's reminding me and I was like oh
yeah that's right we just talked about
this like two days ago
um with Robert but the new Earth and how
it just feels like you know actually
honestly Chemtrails is one of them that
I think to myself I can control like I
can grow my own food I can you know find
a water source there's so many things
that you go I can kind of do that but I
can't do anything about what covers the
entire planet through the in the sky
like I can't I can't do anything about
that so I I think to myself about how do
we get out of this mess and you know the
new Earth thing keeps coming to mind and
while I know that you're in very much in
you know like the
field of
um you know Health through
supplementation and especially what the
soil isn't giving us anymore and what
the sun is barely giving us with the
with all the things going on and various
different things but
um what are your what is your awareness
about that because I've asked so many
people about the new Earth because it
just seems like something my mind has a
hard time comprehending although it's
been something that many have spoken
about for a long time and
um and when we were having this text
conversation about like hey I'm gonna
interview in a couple days any Hot Topic
you want to hit
um and it was at like you know 1 44 p.m
and I was or at 1 44 p.m I had asked
about uh the new Earth and I think
Robert was like well 144 144 000 people
are going to be transitioning to the new
Earth so I continue to get little bits
of information but it almost feels like
there has to be a dimensional shift or
like there'll just be a reality shift
and and and it might not be something
that any of us even know about that get
to move forward or that don't move
forward we won't know we're in it or not
in it it'll just be a new new realm of
reality so
um what are what are your what's what
have you found out about the new Earth
concept
well I I'm a pragmatist and so and I'm
an optimist yeah and but I'm also a
realist and the new Earth concept I'm
here for that that's why I do what I do
and that's why I live with the intention
and that's why my life's work is to
offer guidance
um not through indoctrination but
through embodiment and be a living
example
um as far as the 144 000 or the new
genetic sequence that's going to take in
on the new children there's a lot of
ideas there's a lot of Concepts around
these things
um some of them are extreme some of them
are radical but I'm also a believer that
this world is not what we think it is
and there's so much to it that is
um that is you know it's it's so
spiritual that we couldn't even
complement comprehend it so so there's a
level of irrationality that needs to
happen like when you think about our
world and how these these systems work
it's irrational to a certain extent and
so there's a beauty to that it's like
trusting and believing in something that
doesn't have to be weighed or measured
and some scientist tells you that this
is what it is and I think that we are
heading into a direction where
something has to give it can't keep
going at this velocity in this direction
and through that and through every fire
through every Quake through every
whatever something new is born from that
we have to go through some level of pain
and suffering and that's with the cosmic
law that's part of the cosmic law
so I
um I feel like we put our we have to put
our position put ourselves in position
to be able to move through all this and
it's not in a place of fear it's it's in
a place of trust and you talk about
things that we can control and things
that we can't control and so you met you
meant you mentioned atmospheric spraying
and things of that nature like how do we
control that well the first way that we
control that is we're aware of it number
one number two we're we don't let let it
keep triggering anger and fear and
resentment so we're not getting caught
up in that biochemical wave every single
time we experience it
um and we have these conversations with
our loved ones and we communicate about
it so it's starting to spread and people
are talking about it more you and I are
talking about it just on a small
fractional level but you know there are
100 there's probably millions of people
that are talking about it out there but
there's also billions of people that
don't even look up right so at some
point this has to be communicated to the
to a large scale so we also have to know
where what's happening with with these
things how do we detoxify our body how
do we keep our body in a state of health
while we're going through this and and
these are things that again
planning to fail or failing to plan is
planning to fail we have to have these
conversations we have to have these
meetings we have to have these
gatherings I think we're so isolated in
this world in our in our realm and
social media has created an illusion
that there's connection
when in actuality there is zero
connection well and I mean you know you
say there's no Duality but it sure feels
like there's some so much duality in a
sense that like we are more connected
than ever but we are actually less
connected
to each other than ever from uh physical
emotional
standpoint from a from an energetic
standpoint that's correct you hit it
right on the nail uh we are not creating
momentum directly through connection
right the Sparks of it and there's
things but it's not going anywhere yeah
interesting yeah yeah it's it's and it's
just a form of I don't know
intellectualism or you know it's just
like you're you're creating a dopamine
release but nothing is being followed
through there's physical action there's
no movement we're not becoming stewards
of anything we're just sitting there and
we're feeling good even people that are
into these types of conversations and
things like that we're feeling good
we're okay there's other people talking
about it yeah
nothing changes and then at some point
when you start doing that for three four
five six ten years 15 years you're just
getting caught into the the mental
masturbation of it yeah and that that's
that's a problem and I'm sure the
systems and the things that are running
the system know that we're dealing with
we're dealing with you know IQs you know
high 100s one in the 180s 190s that know
what they're doing in terms of data and
all of these things
this isn't just random you know none of
this is random what do you think is
happening at that macro level what is
that macro level manipulation I mean
there's always lots of theories about
like you know the you know Illuminati or
cabal or various different deep State
and all those things State yeah what's
going on I think they I think there's
many names to it
um so I don't think getting into the
what we call it it means much there is
an an energy that wants control
that wants you know unlimited power
and that energy that
technocratic energy has
um mastered its next Evolution into
technology
you know there you could see it from the
age of Dawn and how it manipulated
different groups and systems from
Freemasonry to Knights of Templar to all
these things you understand it's like a
virus or a parasite it Taps into where
it can it can use its power Flex its
power and infect things and Technology
was the perfect weapon it was a perfect
weapon because you only once you
understand human psychology and
What Makes Us Thrive what makes us tick
what keeps us in a state of fear what
keeps us alive but not able to grow then
you can really manipulate the world and
you know the Advent of social media was
supposed to be the opposite of
mainstream television and but it's
actually become you know even a crazier
weapon and then you have handheld
devices and all these things and now you
have you know virtual reality and video
games and all this crap this stuff is
doing a number to us and so what is
their end game game I don't think
there's an end game I think it's a
constant game I don't think there's it's
it's it's anything that
turns into something else it just
evolves into where the world is taking
it and it's a it's it's it's it's rooted
in greed
it's rooted in fear it's rooted in
indoctrination
um and it's telling a fictitious story
that's where this and it's it's a
disease in in some form
so you don't think it's necessarily a
person a group uh you know a round table
of people it's it's more of a it's more
of a pattern within us like I mean I
think a lot about about a lot of things
being fractal and how while there's some
sort of Overlord macro sort of
energy that's trying to get us into
these negative spaces of materialism and
whatnot there's probably an aspect in me
like that too like in all of us viruses
are essentially how we've evolved I mean
it is because of viruses that we are the
human beings that we are today and have
the resilience that we do and we carry I
think ten percent I looked it up because
I wanted to know more about this but
like 10 of our DNA is like altered by
virus throughout time
and so
it's like this is sort of a different
manifestation but it's still
kind of like us still is that there's an
aspect of us that
is being realized on a macro level but
it's within all of us so it would lead
me to think yeah okay maybe it's not
like a a group
um or of this sort of like like I said
this sort of you know
Illuminating Illuminati group of 100
people that run the world it's just some
aspect of us and we have to figure out
how to evolve past it so that we can
energetically transition shift Elevate
our frequency and and enter a new Earth
I mean you said it perfectly I agree
with you one billion percent to claim
that there's a boogeyman behind the door
you know that's and and having fault
with that boogeyman puts us in that
state of Perpetual cycle
right you feel me on that totally yeah
you're exactly it's a victim mentality
almost it's a victim mentality and
that's powerlessness you're giving your
power to something else then why do you
think Holly weird is depict depicting
these types of movies since the
Inception of movies and film all that
stuff and the stories behind it it's the
boogeyman it's this evil whatever it's
this or that that creates this dualistic
lens that we're constantly going to be
held down by by something or we're going
to constantly have to fight this
something and that's part of this like
two-party system that we're dealing with
in this country the divide and conquer
it's all that same engineering problem
reaction solution you create a problem
there's a reaction you're provide the
solution to the problem you created it's
all psychosis we gotta snap out of we
gotta snap out of this and and step into
our power and stuff or true sovereignty
that's the only way there's no other way
yes yes wow okay dots are connecting I
feel like this makes a lot of sense and
I think we can go back for a second
because you know we had sort of talked
about this offline a little bit with
school and whatnot but it you know I
love the saying that we are one
generation away from a solution right
like if we just get the Next Generation
to think differently to act differently
to be different we are we can really
uh we can really turn the ship we can
really auto correct for the future so I
think schools you know is something that
comes to mind and you know we were kind
of going off about this on our own but I
mean I don't have kids but I think I had
come from an interesting perspective
given the fact that I left high school
when I was 16 I got a GED I never went
to college yet I am a
successful educated intelligent person
that has good you know social skills as
well as like intellectual nature to
being able to digest information
um anyway and I didn't go to school so I
feel like while I don't have kids and I
don't I didn't really participate fully
it's because of it that I have this
ability to talk about it a little bit so
okay so school it seems like if there
was a solution it would be to to to to
go to that next Generation so what is it
that school does wrong and what does it
need to do right
I love this conversation and
school what an interesting term and what
an interesting connotation it creates
when just when you hear the word school
right the word magic behind it you know
school has always represented in the
last 60 70 80 100 years Higher Learning
it's also represented a club right
you're part of a club okay it's actually
a combination of The Higher Learning in
the club that allows you to be
appreciated in the real world because
the schools of is not the real world
it's just part of a process to get to
the real world and that we would
actually put ourselves in debt to go
through that process just just to
position us so the real world accepts us
right so without the school you're not
being accepted by your peers and by your
elders as someone that has the
discipline or has the where wherewithal
or comes from the family to put them
there so there's a there's a hierarchy
there there's a pedigree there and look
I don't want to I don't want to
generalize too much are there
outstanding schools and institutions out
there that are providing incredible
knowledge-based systems and Higher
Learning Systems and expanding
Consciousness and Minds sure but it's
very far in between and the School of
Hard Knocks and the school of life offer
all of those with with way more
versatility and way more aspects in
coding systems that activate your true
potential as opposed to just receiving
information from a doctrine that being
said our state-sponsored school systems
right now in this country are an
absolute Abomination it's an abyss of
controlling and Contracting a child and
that's why I'm a major advocate of
Montessori and Waldorf schools and
nature schools and home school systems
that are built on the fabric of allowing
a child to develop their own faculties
which is a major Steiner perspective a
child has to be building their own
faculties on their own Trust of their
Consciousness and their experiences at
age two at age three at age four at age
five six seven and we now know through
modern technology and modern psychology
about epigenetics and we also know the
biology of belief and we know that from
a third trimester in the womb to age
seven the child is in the Theta brain
Zone which that Theta Hertz signal as a
specific hurts that is an imagination
signal an imagination impulse and an
electrical system for them to receive
everything in their surroundings so they
can learn how things are doing it's that
impulse of of receivership and that's
why that age is so critical that you
have that child in an exploration phase
and you also have them in a phase where
they're not being reprimanded by this
difficult difficult lens of right or
wrong you're allowing them to experience
and learn nuances you're you're
incubating them you're the parent you're
that's your that's your perspective
you're you're holding the line but
you're not force indoctrinating that
child into right or wrong there's
something that develops at age three
four and five if you let a child be free
and it's the most important faculty of
them all what's that intuition oh yeah
intuition is The Guiding Light of this
world dude it's the only foolproof
um lie detector system
by far like tell me a time when your
intuition has told you something about a
job or a person or a relationship or a
some some friend or some situ something
that has been wrong like you can't
because it's true that's correct you're
it's all the senses and the one it's not
just your success and
it's under my belief that
intuition of humanity right now so
suppressed through the these these types
of schooling
you put a seven-year-old eight-year-old
nine-year-old in a chair at eight A.M
under you know blue light
and you start them on a curriculum
that's not exciting that's not opening
up their mind and hearts that's not
connecting them to Spirit you are
suppressing everything in that child
and most people and I could never stay
in my classroom as a kid I was known to
not being able to stand let's move
around I couldn't sit there I had to
climb a tree I had to run around I had
to I was I was losing I think they go
way too young I mean I just think kids
go way too young they're so exploratory
they want to climb a tree they want to
go like build a fort in the living room
they're so creative you know my sister's
kids were over here building like a with
like you know diff like the Jenga blocks
was building like a farm with animals
and I'm like great you know they they
just are so creative when you go to
school they're like one plus one equals
two sit in this spot on the floor or
you're in trouble and if you have to go
to the bathroom you're just gonna have
to wait because it's not the bathroom
break yet and you know color in the
lines and nope ducks are not blue ducks
are yellow you know or whatever it is
it's like it's just there's no image
nation and essentially imagination and
creativity are like really fundamental
to our expansion
that's it we're we're art we need to be
artists first the art and the creativity
has to expand at that age when you
suppress it you're suppressing all of
the evolutionary codes of a child and by
the time they're 10 11 12
they're a shell of their evolutionary
State and that's why you have so many
kids that are angry and frustrated and
withdrawn and you know they go they they
they
become loners they get addicted to
things they get addicted to terrible
Foods they get addicted to drugs they
get addicted to alcohol they get
addicted to porn it's not it's not
shocking it's they really are they have
no idea and then they have a parent they
have parents that have no idea who they
are and everyone's confused and we're in
that cycle right now we're in generation
of loss where it's 2 20 23. I mean this
has been going on for quite some time
now it's a habitual cycle and you throw
in all the other stressors of life and
then you throw on social media and then
you're showing all the the filters and I
can go on and on it's just crazy where
we're at if I create like a pie chart of
showing all the little tiny nuances of
all the things that children have to
deal with it's Insanity levels there and
it hurts me deeply found it that's one
of the things that it's hard for me to
just like say this is the cosmic giggle
it's fundamentally hurting me throwing
the foods that they're eating throwing
their you know the schedules that
they're on it's crazy and so
um fundamentally if we can get back to
bringing incubation energies around
children getting them back into the
Earth teaching them something like
growing their own garden yeah
like think about it a hundred years ago
about 95 of the population had a direct
connection to the food that they ate
either they grew it or their neighbor
grew it okay today it's a decimal
fraction of one percent okay just think
how big of a deal that is yeah how huge
that is that means that we are we don't
know where our food comes from
where our feet aren't in the earth a
child
isn't given the opportunity to learn
about what it takes to grow food and how
much effort goes into that oh God just
growing a sweeping
wow it takes that long I value this I
value this
that builds something called empathy
it's an empathetic lens to know how hard
it was to grow something when you're
about to take it in as your food source
it's a big deal we need to go back to
these things this is pivotal to where
we're trying to head as a society yeah
well and that's that's that that was my
next question was just about what is the
future like you know you have a magic
wand and you can wave it and this is how
we move forward
um or this is even just how you move
forward
um
how do we get back on track
and is it enough if we just do it
ourself
starts with self
we can't worry about what's happening
you know in the next County in the next
state in the next whatever it has to
start internally
has to shift internally
you know look at your daily life look at
the things that you guys are that are
consuming your time like create a chart
and say okay this is the time we're
doing this so much time we're doing this
okay well where can we start modifying
this you know where can we start
creating through elimination right and
it starts with small things here and
there listening to the Danica Patrick
Show you know you know like okay we're
not going to watch this TV or we're not
going to get consumed and you know
um gossip right gossip is a big part of
this whole thing too it's like everyone
cares about everyone's downfall it's
like that's a parasitic energy
um how are we gonna start spending more
quality time with our loved ones how are
we going to start you know changing our
lifestyle like we're going to start
getting up earlier we're going to start
we're going to move away from the two
three glasses of wine a night we're
gonna start looking at all the you know
the foods that we're eating who are we
supporting and where our dollar goes are
we connecting to you know the the
farmers that are local like do we go to
farmers markets and get to know those
people and support them you know because
more influx of energy and more intention
then you have more energy that goes
there and supports things that are going
to create and inspire better health for
people there's small little things that
we can do that if everyone starts doing
it
it makes a huge change yeah all day long
on social media just like losing our
mind who are we following on social
media sure the audit audit that got to
do an audit like why are why are we
attracted to this what is it what is it
telling us about ourselves that you know
this is what we're into and the things
that are internal stuff it's all
internal and where are we where are we
casting judgment on to other people
is it something that we hate within
ourselves of course always
well we judge weed and I you know if you
could name a couple of things that you
think have made the biggest difference
in your life that you've done what would
they be
well I I
changed course drastically on
my network of people yeah
yeah you know I've lost childhood
friends and Friends of 15 years because
I just had to make the decision that my
life mattered
and that my time mattered and when the
circle got smaller the vision got way
larger
that's number one and in doing such it
also put me in a position where I had to
call myself higher because it's always
like okay eliminate those around you but
also look at yourself how are you
showing up for people
that was that was really important
um you know also
my uh just my my rituals
right what were the non-negotiables that
I needed to keep and it's not living
this like militaristic regimen in life
but it's knowing like at least five six
days a week I'm in bed by 10 pm and I'm
up at 5 30 a.m and I'm doing my rituals
I'm I have those in place because I
understand that those are key to my body
and brain functioning properly so I can
make the right decisions
um you know committing myself to to my
work and my journey and showing up for
my you know what what I'm doing
those are powerful things and then just
my meditation you know being able to go
into the higher Realms
um outside of the physical body and the
self of being sharing those are things
you know getting out of my comfort zone
oh that's a good one jumping in my cold
plunge you know going into 160 degree
saunas jumping in the ocean uh inverting
you know hanging upside down for five
minutes you know whatever it is
sprinting crazy cliff diving you know
all the crazy stuff those are things
that get you out of your comfort zone
but they're keeping me healthy and Alive
yeah yeah
like this you know thank you and thank
you for um just sharing your truth and
encouraging all of us to do the same and
just ultimately stepping into our
sovereignty so that you know we can save
this beautiful reality and planet that
we live in instead of disrupting it
which again How We Do Anything Is How We
Do everything so if we're going about it
in a destructive manner for ourselves
it's the same for the planet and vice
versa
Danica I receive all that and I
appreciate you you're uh just a
reflection of me within you and that's
why I see myself in you and it's um
it's a it's an amazing time to be alive
yeah and it's an amazing time to be in
our bodies and to be operating in our
freedom and our discernment and anyone
listening to this you know just know
that you're the master Magician of your
reality and it's never too late to take
your life back grab the reins of your
life and just 24 hours 48 hours 72 hours
a week and everything can be different
that's real and that was so true you're
one decision away from an entirely
different life totally yeah I'm excited
for part two we'll get you out here to
California love it you want to wake the
fake up yeah I love it and I love that
show yeah I I want to I really want to
know your your background and you and I
have a we're going to be racing a little
bit too so well you have all the cars
and I have the skills so that's right
that's right and we both love our black
on black cars which I respect yes yeah
another part of being human too you know
it's it's another thing is don't shame
yourself in things that
um you love we're in this earth
playground we just need to find balance
man at the end of the day a lot of times
what everything gets sort of like
deduced down to is it's just here to
having it you're here for an experience
yeah you know you're just here to enjoy
it and you know we're not here to be in
fear we're not here to be angry we're
just here to enjoy it and can you
imagine the world we live in if everyone
was just enjoy because when you hurt
someone you're not in Joy that's for
sure right and so you know that would be
that's a that's a that's a beautiful
world that you can imagine
yep and we're in it right now but I
won't feel bad when I beat you
you know ladies first okay oh don't do
that don't do that I do I knew that was
gonna get you going all right we'll
compete all right sounds good all right
well thank you so much
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button